Speaker 1: Marjorie Taylor GREENE going from
one lunatic extremist Republican and Sarah
Palin to another lunatic extremist Republican.
And Marjorie Taylor.
GREENE Marjorie Taylor GREENE says, listen,
it's okay that I believe things that aren't
true because lots of my followers believe
things that aren't true.
These are my words, not hers.
My guess is she would put it a little bit
differently.
But let's listen to what Marjorie Taylor GREENE
had to say on this.
It looks like it looks like this program is
from the nineties.
Night Talk is the name of the show.
Check this out.
Speaker 3: I think the Atlanta paper tells
me that ten days ago you were still insisting
at a Trump rally in Arizona that Trump has
won the 2020 election and it says he, she
and one of his biggest allies.
I am always proud to support President Trump,
Judy.
I'm so grateful for the way he led our country
with his America first policies.
I miss him very much being our president,
and so do a lot of people.
And I do.
I say all the time, I really feel like he
won the state of Georgia and I.
Speaker 1: Feel like he won the state of Georgia.
Now, is there a factual basis there?
No.
But she case she feels it.
Speaker 3: And I do think he won the 2020
election.
But she want to know something.
It's okay for me to say that because a lot
of people feel the same way.
Speaker 1: Right?
This is actually super important.
They justify their investigations and their
claims about the 2020 election by saying,
lots of people feel this way.
Lots of people believe this.
But the reason that lots of people feel that
way and believe it is because people like
Marjorie Taylor GREENE told them that it's
true.
Now, I'm not excusing anyone, right?
It's not.
If Marjorie Taylor GREENE told me Trump won,
I wouldn't believe it unless I had actual
evidence that suggested that.
But it's a vicious circle.
This is like the Marco Rubio Dropbox thing
last week, or I think maybe it was the week
before at this point.
Senator from Florida, Marco Rubio, who's a
Republican, he's running against Val Demings.
Val Demings as a Democratic congresswoman
who now is running for Senate.
And one of the best debate performances, by
the way, was that by Val Demings.
But there was a certain point when the topic
of election integrity, as they like to call
it, came up where Mark or Marco Rubio said,
well, listen, there's two reasons why we should
be against these ballot drop boxes.
One, someone could bomb the ballot drop box,
which hasn't happened.
And it was interesting that he was giving
people that idea.
And he said the second reason is people don't
really trust the ballot drop boxes.
But at the time we said, well, why don't people
trust the ballot drop boxes?
Because Marco and others are telling them
they aren't trustworthy.
So is that really can you really use a belief
you created as a reason why some things should
change in the way you want it to change?
This is like a when Trump says a lot of people
are really angry about what happened in 2020.
And so we have to look into it.
Well, they're angry because you lied to them
and made them angry based on things that aren't
true, claims that are completely debunked.
And if you apply this, I mean, imagine that
Marjorie Taylor GREENE or whoever said, listen,
I think Jews will not replace us is a really
important thing for us to talk about, because
a lot of my constituents feel the same way.
They're worried about the Jews replacing us.
So I think it's an it's a totally logical
thing to talk about.
We wouldn't accept that.
At least many of us would not.
Maybe some of Marjorie Taylor GREENE followers
would so understand that they use the beliefs
they created in others to justify their continued
pursuit and further lies about these issues.
It's an endless circle.
There's this term, dark, sarcastic closure
that is sometimes used to describe this, where
there's you can't.
Your universe reinforces the very beliefs
you are in.
This is often the case with religious beliefs,
and I know that some in the audience may not
like this analogy.
One of the things that often happens with
religious beliefs is people say, Here's my
beliefs because this is what my sacred texts
tell me to believe.
And so they are true.
And then you say, Okay, what evidence do you
have that these sacred beliefs are really
sacred beliefs given by God?
They say, Well, the sacred texts themselves
say that they are sacred.
And then you try to exit the bubble and say,
right, but what do we have from outside of
that?
That tells us these are the sacred beliefs
given by God.
They don't have anything, but it doesn't matter.
The very claim within those sacred beliefs
is self-perpetuating by virtue of saying These
are the sacred beliefs of God and you can't
pierce it.
Sometimes you can't, but it's very difficult
to pierce it.
Same type of thing with this voter fraud stuff.